I'm so proud of us for just getting up
early and going at the climate March
yeah thanks for making me do this well
as I always say it's not good enough for
you to tweet climate models predicts
that by the year 2100 there's gonna be 3
billion more people on this planet and
an increased temperature of 1.8 to 4.0
degrees Celsius good job everybody for
taking transit we need to be saying no
to drive it oh my god what the was
that peanut butter and tail sandwich you
just use a low density polyethylene wrap
to cover your sandwich that requires
fossil fuels and goes in a landfill well
what did you use I recycled milk bag duh
well I make up for it in other ways
stupid things about this luggage keep it
down I'd like to walk everywhere it's
essential well each pair of trainers
uses coal and generates 30 pairs of
emissions something equivalent to leave
a hundred watt light bulb running for a
ball wow you sure seem to know a lot for
something with no brain made out of a
bunch of fat prick say me shoes are made
up of so many materials that made it
faster is complex in fact most units are
made of small machines powered by coal
ok I'll try to become a less of a high B
just keep it down yes it has come to our
attention that you had a particularly
long shower this morning creating excess
water waste you were burning candles and
listening to a sure Oh were you jerking
off in the shower again Greg I told you
that way so much water
I was tired how else are you supposed to
perk up in the morning is it look forget
out in here no I mean yes I usually have
a reusable water bottle I'm white for
pete's sake now jeans are like part of
our culture just thought I forgot it and
I needed this quickly to soothe my
throat after a spicy beef patty be
saying okay this is insane I'm super
environmentally conscious I recycle in
the winter I put on a sweater instead of
turning up the heat like most of the
world doesn't even freaking care
well just by living here in Toronto and
anywhere in the Western world you are a
huge contributor the poorest 50% of the
world only contributes to 10% of global
emissions just by living in wealthy
Canada you are contributing way more
than most people on this planet I can't
help where I live and there's climate
change deniers out there and those are
the people that were going to protest
against that's rich coming from a guy
whose sign is made on cardboard from a
new air conditioning unit we're friggin
subway vent your sole purpose is to heat
and cool people using energy all the
friggin time well right now it sounds
like you're trying to vent I'm just
helping you weak humans maintain
homeostasis don't control me okay I'll
just sit down and be quiet then tough
day yes it's just about doing your best
that's what you always tell me and maybe
you could work on being a little less
condescending well it feels like I'm
being really attacked right now yeah
well your shirt does say anyone who
drives or has ever driven maybe you
could dial it back a little bit so that
you can relate yeah I guess that's true
Oh know what I have to fart but isn't
methane gas like a huge contributor to
greenhouse gas emissions right I'm
pretty sure that's just cattle and
melting ice oh okay what that's like a
negligible amount of gas that comes to
the environment fasting dial it back
with the beef patty French law said
thank you for watching we are always
trying to give ways that we can make
science cool and interesting to
different types of people so that's why
we played around with this style of
video we have a ton of fun making this
video let us know if you have any other
science sketch ideas who wants to tackle
and by the way Greg smart was real in
that video
no it wasn't it was not real but I did
fart on command while we were filming
and one scene but it didn't make the cut
but I was pretty yeah that's just a
natural talent that you have make sure
you subscribe for more animated videos
that come out every Thursday and more
videos like this as well we'll see you
later peace